é gente eu queria muito que vocês
estivessem tão animado quanto eu porque
eu acabei de mudar a apresentação
inteira é eu queria agradecer muito a
todos a organização porque mais do que
vir trazer uma idéia é inspirar as
pessoas e eu estou me sentindo
extremamente inspirada é eu vou falar de
criança
então por mais que eu tenha neve indo
arrumada palestrante me sentindo a
madonna com esse microfone sonho da
minha vida vou tirar o sapato para a
gente poder conversar melhor com quem eu
vou ficar dentro da bolinha vermelha
então aqui então vocês mas vocês vão ver
as minhas crianças e muito do que a
gente faz é aos sábados à tarde
meu nome é ana paula carvalho eu sou
fisioterapeuta até às seis da tarde e à
noite faço letras e outras muitas coisas
é só de santa rita de ibitipoca tem
maior orgulho disso não faz questão de
sempre mencionar queria muito que a
minha fala dentro de tudo o que foi dito
hoje inspirar se você expansão mais do
que nessa coisa de o brilhantismo do ted
você irá assistir todas as palestras e
se inspirar e se motivar
está na hora de colocar a mão na massa e
eu acho que ainda que guardadas as
devidas proporções néel aviva seja uma
ação pequena dentro do universo dentro
da realidade do mundo dentro da pobreza
da somália dentro do estupro da índia
néon uma realidade que muda a vida de
muita gente
todo mundo me pergunta o que quer à viva
é uma cromwell que significa a junção de
várias palavras não aviva né do verbo
rivard tornar mais vivo de tornar mais
intenso que é o que elas que as crianças
fazem com todos nós que nos permitimos
participar todos os sábados à tarde é
vou contar um pouquinho dá origem à semi
prolongar muito eu tive a oportunidade
de fazer um intercâmbio na espanha
quando estava cursando que o trabalho
ainda e começou a fazer frio engordei 17
quilos
então eu fazia alguma coisa da vida ou
então no rio
voltarei amanhã e me queira de volta e
eu voltar eu olhei me voluntariei numa
associação também chamar viva que leva o
mesmo nome e comecei a participar da
rotina é daquelas daqueles deficientes
que na espanha tem uma formação
completamente diferente e que tinha um
perfil diferente porque eles eram todos
adultos
foi o que me salvou não só dos 17 quilos
dos 40 que adquire se eu não tivesse
entrado mas principalmente da solidão e
de uma coisa foi falada aqui que é
extremamente importante
como diria platão também é nenhum homem
é uma ilha
nós somos seres sociais a gente cada dia
mais eu tenho essa certeza a gente às
vezes se pega é tendo dificuldade de
comunicação de diálogo nessa coisa da
rede tão da mídia tão social tão forte
tão presente na vida da gente mas a
sensação que eu tenho aquela aproxima
quem está muito longe e afasta quem está
muito perto
então pra mim foi meu minha salvação na
minha tábua de salvação conviver com
aquelas pessoas me sentir amada poder
amar
acho que é uma coisa muito minha eu
tenho muito amor pra dar
então veio da idéia quando eu voltei
colocar em prática escrevi foi muito
difícil primeiro primeiro ano e meio foi
burocrático cheio de entrave cheio de
problemas e conseguimos fazer um plano
piloto com algumas crianças convidadas
que eram meus pacientes
os primeiros foram meus pacientes que eu
conhecia a realidade
eu tenho um perfil natural sapato e
gosto de criança eu gosto de
contabilidade da criança eu gosto dessa
liberdade que a criança de tarde sentir
não é porque a gente vai ficando velho
vai endurecendo e nada pode né quem
estudou em colégio militar
tudo tem que ser muito faca na caveira e
quando com as crianças não é lanche e
reconstroem o tempo todo se desconstrói
o tempo todo e eu sempre tive muita
afinidade então por isso que a gente
mudou um pouco o perfil para trazer para
a realidade e hoje nossas crianças elas
têm idades entre 5 e 14 anos é nós
atendemos crianças de 5 a 14 anos com
todos os tipos de deficiência desde que
obedeçam um grau de funcionalidade
isso porque eu vou falar um pouquinho
mais para frente por tudo
conta muito do perfil do do voluntariado
então nós temos algumas nem ter um
pouquinho de limite por causa mesmo do
manuseio das crianças e do tipo de
atividade que a proposta é sabella ela
volta com a gente desde o início também
tem síndrome de down
essa é a nossa lindinha e vinha na
atividade de piscina e vocês vão ver
várias crianças todas elas muito
diferentes entre elas mas todas elas
muito criança não é que acho que uma das
coisas
uma das experiências mais sensacionais
que a gente teve duas reuniões de de uma
das reuniões de voluntários que com uma
vontade é ser quando é assim aquela
coisa de armas e terapeuta você sabe que
a criança tem o que aquela criança tenha
clique em ao fulano não tem nada ela é
filha de uma voluntária então como a
gente consegue normatizar as crianças
naquele ambiente aponta as pessoas não
saberem quem tem uma data é uma
deficiência que é tão estigmatizada na
sociedade e uma criança que é normal
porque a gente consegue fazer o ambiente
e que em todas elas vão ali para brincar
e serem crianças é a gente teve e eu
particularmente tive uma vivência muito
importante com a vitória que é uma
criança que nasceu com uma má formação
genética ela não tem os dois braços todo
mundo vendo bem e ela está colorindo
melhor que eu inclusive que sou péssimo
treino muito e o primeiro dia dela foi
nosso encerramento de 2012 no parque da
laginha ea gente fez uma roda na ilha
desse jeito fala demais não sei que
'para quem vem pela primeira vez levanta
a mão aí vou montar se olhar a gente não
tem que fingir que ela tem mão é só tem
cumprimentá lo assim não é
ela nasceu sem os braços ea normatização
não venha a partir do momento que você
finge que ela tem o braço vem no momento
em que você aceita ela não ter que fazer
tudo que todo mundo faz
foi uma experiência muito marcante ruim
porque né ela sem pensar na hora que eu
falei isso ela levantou o pé sem pensar
ea gente que fica no conjunto de
conceitos dos adultos com os problemas e
foi uma experiência muito positiva até
dos voluntários é que poderão ver isso
como a criança se adapta e como ela
aceita e veste a a deficiência dela
lógico que é muito difícil quando
por exemplo já tem uma vida adulta sofre
um acidente e pede um braço mas a
criança nasceu sem ela não sabe que a
experiência de ter um braço toda ela
quando alguém fala
levanta a mão não pensa duas vezes é a
gente tem nossas crianças numa atividade
inicial que é uma coisa que a gente
sempre preza muito nossas atividades
acontecem todos os sábados de três a
cinco da tarde
nessas duas horas a gente divide a
atividade um primeiro momento que a
gente chama de acolhida
é um momento que brasileiro chega
atrasada pela dificuldade de organização
e que a gente tenta elaborar mais a
parte cognitiva artística e
principalmente a partir da expressão das
crianças é a gente tem muitas crianças
têm muita dificuldade na fala então a
comunicação oral delas é muito
prejudicada e uma criança especial
sempre me tocou muito porque ela era
tido como uma criança agressiva mas eu
também seria agressiva e minhas costas
vem encostando não poder nem eu costumo
pedir a ninguém eu também britânicos pin
todo mundo então você tem que encontrar
uma forma com que a criança expressa
universo que tem dentro dela a gente
consiga fazer entender né o poder do
diálogo onde está até onde comunicar é
realmente a fala só que é necessário tem
tantas formas de comunicação de
expressão do corpo do olhar e hoje essas
crianças nessas crianças fisicamente o
botão ele é o nosso xodozinho é nosso
menino alento porque ele conseguiu sacar
uma porque ele conseguiu ver que as
pessoas prestar atenção nele as pessoas
têm interesse pelo universo que existe
dentro dele
vou tentar não chorar vão ver que é
difícil porque não tenho vínculo muito
forte com isso tudo como foi falado bom
já andré maggi não tem que ficar fazendo
um script para a fala é porque é tão
meio isto é uma paixão tão grande que eu
tenho que sair né as informações fluem
com muita facilidade
é o thales é uma criança com a gente há
um ano e meio ele é autista e tem uma
atividade mensal de interação e esse foi
um dia lindo que não vou lutar do lado
dele brincando com uma bola e fazer uma
atividade tranquila com ele e me fale
aceitou companhia
então isso para a gente são ganhos
diários que a gente consegue
e que talvez eu tenho até que me
policiar um pouco pra não ter sempre
olhar terapêutico
isso é uma coisa mais livre e ver que os
ganhos são muito mais significativos
para as famílias por exemplo do que pra
gente essa atividade muito legal que a
gente fez foi o que ele está implantando
uma uma mudinha como tem aqui hoje
também e aí o nosso grupo
somos muito né não falei em relação às
crianças nós temos 46 crianças
cadastradas
existe um fluxo muito grande né porque
nossas crianças são mais frágeis então é
aos sábados a nossa média de 25 crianças
por sábado elas saibam a data em que o
dia mais complicado então por isso que
existe essa oscilação muito grande
o perfil do voluntário que agora voltará
a vender o peixe espera ganhar vários
voluntários aqui hoje é pessoas que
tenham propriedades que tenham
consciência da função que você tem
dentro de uma sociedade porque talvez
seja um pouco radical nessa nesse
posicionamento mas as pessoas estão na
imprensa é muito bonzinho ou nada
boazinha meu passada negra e não tem não
tem essa conotação a minha ideia do
aviva se estou há seis anos com todos os
meus sábados comprometidos se eu estou
há seis anos levando isso juntamente com
todos os voluntários com todas as
famílias hoje a carol vai me acompanhar
que é uma voluntária que tá não é com a
gente desde o início também é graças a
uma consciência
eu acho que quando nem foi falado muito
de política do ser humano todos nós
enquanto seres políticos
isso é ótimo é uma coisa fundamental
você ter consciência da sua importância
nessa engrenagem não é altruísmo não é
talvez seja até egoísmo ea parte porque
o que recarrega as minhas filhas de toda
a semana
é impressionante se eu tivesse que dar
um perfil de voluntários e são pessoas
que querem fazer alguma coisa então tem
que ser formado em fisioterapia não tem
que ser é terapeuta ocupacional não tem
que ter cuidado mas não tenho
experiência com criança com quem te
talvez você esteja precisando que dessas
20 disso dessa experiência
então nosso perfil hoje tem desde
engenheiros elétricos até o que a gente
tem agora muito forte e espero
fortalecer ainda mais que a parceria com
as empresas juniores e foi falar aqui
também tem sempre o lado de
responsabilidade social eu acho incrível
tenho acompanhado o movimento das
empresas juntas principalmente aqui na
na universidade
é incrível porque eles mudam as pessoas
isso é impressionante então nosso perfil
tenha boa vontade têm disponibilidade e
queira experience ar coisas diferentes é
semana retrasada nós vemos oportunidade
única que para quem é de fora nem
conhece o cultural é uma balada e tal
noitada e ter um evento no domingo e
depois levar as crianças lá e era da
internet amplo é camila acha que ninguém
sabe o que fazer e eu pular como a
criança todo mundo olhando me assustado
né mesmo tempo que se tem que ter uma
coisa é ter cuidado não tem treinando
tem que botar a criança vai te dizer é
que eu não tinha eu não ando de costa
não tinha nome pega assim ela vai te
dizer os limites
somos nós que nos em que a gente põe a
nós mesmos e aos outros
às vezes você trata de senti como se
fosse uma coisa que é brava gente todo
mundo cai todo mundo machucar todo mundo
vai passar por isso na vida
então é importante que eles tenham se
isso era até é sempre um problema em
falar com os pais e os pais
principalmente deficientes têm essa
tendência superprotegê a querer mas ele
já tem tanta dificuldade
nós somos seres que precisamos
dificuldade fácil nos atrás né
a gente precisa de barreira e essas
crianças mais do que qualquer uma elas
precisam do desafio
então às vezes a gente vá acontecer o
estande voluntário e me dar não pode o
futebol hoje não porque o fluminene não
está na cadeira e aí ele vai conseguir
jogar vai sentir frustrado por mês a
vida não é só flores não a gente tem que
aprender a lidar e ele precisa questão
de adaptação a gente consegue um pé de
manga de jogar com a mão a gente
consegue colocar no chão como goleiro
ele consegue ter um gol pouco o futebol
pra trás ex-jogador sentada
então é só você tem vontade querer
adaptar que tudo flui bem e seu uso nas
atividades adaptadas na cesta de
basquete
e os meninos todos a gente tem
as atividades são muito diversas é não
definir exatamente hoje nós somos um
instituto que instituto viva que presta
serviço de esporte adaptado e atividades
lúdicas desportivas adaptados para
crianças de 5 a 14 anos
então cada sábado a gente tem um esporte
diferente aqui no campo a gente tem o
dia do judô que foi emocionante muito
bonito ver um profissional é que o
lutador aposentado mas continua atuando
aula
o basquete ou aqui embaixo a gente tem o
vôlei sentado
é uma atividade muito legal foi um time
de vôlei em que participou no dia ele
tem dois metros de altura quando colocou
todo mundo sentado pra jogar com aquela
coisa você nem vê lo e acho que eles
ficaram meio sem jeito é as atividades
são muito diferentes ea gente tinha
quando na teoria nem quando ele escreve
o projeto as coisas tinham outro caráter
e não sabia como ia ser muito essa
questão da escolinha de esporte em que
diversos fundamentos do esporte que
tivesse o ganho habilidade e eu tinha
muito essa por gostar muito de esporte
eu tinha muita vontade de aplicar os
conceitos esporte disciplina do coletivo
da cooperação e principalmente aqueles
que despertasse nas crianças essa
vontade de vir a ser um atleta
paraolímpico que vem nós teremos nada
dentro de casa
as olimpíadas e as paraolimpíadas e a
gente tem que ter muita vontade
só que a gente vai vendo que o esporte
se você não repete mas não tem ganho e
aí a gente conseguir as crianças que
chegam não tinha eu quero brincar as
crianças têm uma vida super corrida mas
o que empresário a rotina delas é o
tempo todo treinando por tratamentos de
manhã fono de tarde é fisio de até 40
habitacional e musicoterapia até por
essa ansiedade dos pais em querer
proporcionar todas as coisas possíveis
porque essas crianças precisam de um
estímulo
elas não têm tempo para ser feliz elas
não têm tempo para serem crianças para
brincar de pique pra brincar de queimada
para acabar a lan lan então chegou no
sábado só não tão cansada de terapia eu
não ia colocar tudo regrado né
vamos lá passa com a direita páscoa
que lógica a gente utiliza a nossa
ferramenta esporte a gente usa os
fundamentos das crianças também
aprenderem e se desenvolverem
mas a gente sabe que aquele momento
apenas relaxar em elas serem crianças
hoje que tem um dia que o futebol ea
menina não quer jogar aí outro dia que
ninguém podia de natação porque a
unanimidade dos voluntários dão mais
trabalho do que as crianças
eles são os nossos contatos espero que
todos vocês entrem em contato para
mandar uma mensagem para falar da
experiência de vocês e eu queria muito
agradecer por poder dividir porque
quando eu fui convidada
eu achei genial nessa ideias que merecem
ser compartilhadas
eu acredito muito que essa é uma idéia
que deve ser compartilhada porque ela é
extremamente que aplicável e você pode
fazer qualquer realidade em qualquer
escola em qualquer bairro em qualquer
cidade e hoje
de acordo com o último censo a população
de deficiência de 24,7 por cento da
população
então não existe mais isso de que eles
fazem parte de uma minoria que eles são
excluídos que estão alijados da
sociedade e isso é um quarto cd conta
com um quarto da população brasileira e
uma coisa que eu sempre trago como
conscientização para todo mundo é que a
questão da política agora acabam de
aprovar o estatuto decente ea questão
das políticas públicas a questão da
acessibilidade isso não é obrigação
responsabilidade do deficiente isso a
sociedade como um todo principalmente
porque a gente nunca sabe o futuro né
a gente está aqui pode tropeçar na
escada quebrada uma vértebra e virar um
tetraplégico
eu precisava ou mesmo temporário nem
sequer uma pena ser uma muleta
tem que usar cadeira de rodas durante um
tempo e principalmente eles fazem parte
da sociedade se hoje existem políticas
de cota de 1 por cento na porcentagem
dentro das empresas é porque as pessoas
tomaram consciência então a gente
precisa fazer a diferença
ok eu quero deixar para vocês uma frase
que a minha minha para mim mesma mas que
eu acho que traduz essa parte que nós
tivemos aqui que nunca perca a
capacidade de se maravilhar com as
coisas enquanto seus olhos brilharem por
alguma coisa
este possibilidade de vida a quem
encerra a minha fala que espero todas as
perguntas possíveis
eu adoro falar então perguntei muito
rock